اطلقوا على انفسهم حراس الطبيعه استوطنوا
الغابات واتخذوا الاشجار والطيور اصدقاء
لهم
هنا تزور السحب قيمه ما الجبال في مشهد
بديع وتتحول احلام السكان الى واقع حقيقي
يعيشونه كل يوم نحن الان في احدى مناطق
نيوزلندا حيث يتحد البشر والطبيعه في كيان
واحد المناظر الخلابه هنا انجبت العديد من
عشاق الطبيعه عالم نباتات متقاعد يدعى هو
واحد من هؤلاء المسحورين بالطبيعه رفض
استخدام وسائل الاتصال الحديثه لاكثر من
اربعين عاما ولم يسبق له انقاذ سياره او
لمس هاتفا نقالا هيوجوا دراجته والغابه
صداقه من نوع خاص
قررت منذ عده سنوات انني ساسافر فقط
باستخدام الدراجه الهوائيه او سيرا على
الاقدام انا احب ذلك حقا وسافعل ذلك حتى
لو لم اكن هناك لان ذلك مفيد لصحتك
كرس حياته مدافعا عن النباتات وحيوانات
الغابه اشترى قبل 24 عاما قطاعا واسعه من
الاراضي غير صالحه للاستخدام بالقرب من
منزله وقرر تحويلها الى محميه غابات
نحن نعتمد كليا على الطبيعه نحن مرتبطون
تماما بالانظمه البيئيه المختلفه لكنها
تضررت في جميع انحاء العالم اعتقد انه امر
جيد في حياتي ان اتاكد من استعاده بعض
النظم البيئيه الاساسيه في الجزء الذي
اعيش فيه من العالم
الوحيد بالاشجار هنا الطيار جيري ايضا
تربى في اسره عاشقه للغابات
وسخر وظيفته لخدمه وحمايه الحيوانات
والنباتات في نيوزلندا عن طريق العمل مع
حراس الحدائق الوطنيه
كان والدي عالم نباتات وعندما كنت صغيرا
كان يصطحبني وبقيه افراد عائلتي الى
الغابه كلما استطاع علمنا الاسماء
والانواع المختلفه للاشجار والطيور
عزله نيوزلندا اهالتها لتصبح موطنا للعديد
من الاشجار والحيوانات لكن ورغم انها ارض
فريده الا ان التدخل البشري والحيوانات
المفترسه يهددان هذا التوازن الطبيعي
ولهذا يحلق جيري بطائراته فوق الغابات
لمساعده علماء النباتات والحيوانات
ليقوموا بمهامهم في استعاده التوازن
البيئي
النباتات والحيوانات في هذا المكان على ما
هي عليه دائما
فهنا لديك مثال رائع لنبته ستنمو لتصبح
شجره ضخمه في الوقت الحالي تبدو مثل
العنكبوت الصغير انا احب الطبيعه الجانب
الصاخبه والجانب الصامته منها تعطيك
الطبيعه اسرارها وتجعلك تدرك كم هي ثمينه
جميع اشكال الحياه
[موسيقى]
الطبيعه في نيوزلندا تتاثر بالمتغيرات حول
العالم كزياده استهلاك الطاقه والتجريف
الغابات ولهذه الاسباب يوغو جيري وغيرهما
من حراس الغابه وهبوا حياتهم لحمايه
البيئه والحفاظ على الطبيعه